The Willows hedgehog Center in
Bromsgrove like dozens of others across
the UK is full the mild weather is
largely to blame for the problem it's
meant many hedgehogs have had litters
later in the year too late for the
youngsters or hoglets to put on enough
weight to survive hibernation we've been
going nine years over nine years and
this is the first time we have ever
closed our doors for new admissions
we've never had to do it before it's
only through the kindness of foster
carers like Sam that spaces can be freed
up to allow new admissions well I've
always been really fascinated by
hedgehogs and I saw the advert on
Facebook here couple years ago so I just
rang in had to chat to Jane came and
tried it out really enjoyed it and
obviously because she gets so many
hedgehogs come in particularly at this
time of year I thought it'd be really
helpful to her if I could help out with
the fostering so I did and it's just
gone from there the latest figures from
the RSPCA show the number of hedgehogs
admitted to its wildlife centres is up
twenty-two percent so far this year from
January to the end of October more than
2000 hedgehogs were brought in that's
compared to 1739 over the same period
last year
an average of twelve hedgehogs were
taken into the centres every day in
October
that's roughly one every two hours of
course there are guidelines to be
followed if you're considering fostering
a hedgehog or a hoglet as cute as he may
be he's certainly not a pet the advice
is that they shouldn't be kept inside a
house if you want to look after one you
need a garage or a shed and it's not
yours to keep he is going to be released
back into the wild
the Hedgehog is one of Britain's
favourite wild animals but popularity is
no guarantee of protection we're well
aware that Hedgehog numbers in this
country are in serious decline people
are aware of the plight of the Hedgehog
so when they're seeing these youngsters
when they're seeing these small
hedgehogs that are going to be too small
to survive hibernation they're acting we
will take him
there's his reference number so if you
want an update send us a text message
and when we
got time we will respond so the advice
is if you see a small hedgehog at any
time or a larger one during the day you
need to help wearing gloves pick it up
weigh it if you can and contact your
local rescue center that's what Emma did
and that's why this lucky little chap
will now be able to survive the winter
Fraser Maud skynews Bromsgrove